chris i honestly can count on one hand
the number of people who i met whose
money we managed
whose goal was to make a lot of money
not even five it's actually four
and i remember each one of them because
guess what they are [ __ ]
and and they just they never have enough
and they always want more than the next
guy
and they're covetous and they're jealous
and they're
envious and those are the most
destructive sins because you can't have
any fun with them i mean
at least gluttony and then that you're
going to enjoy it
right
jim o'shaughnessy welcome to the show
christopher great to see you
great to see you as well look at you in
your airpod pro max
so these changed my life
i got them as a gift um i had the kind
of headphones you have on for most of
when we did went remote on
infinite loops those were fine
um and my son patrick was like dad
and you know he's the podcast king so
he's like
you got to get these they'll change your
life they have like i don't know how
many microphones in them
and when we were testing them well let
me put it this way my wife's a street
photographer
in manhattan i won't talk to her with
these on if she's on the street
because i hear everything she doesn't
hear
they're like ridiculously good and then
my producer was like okay let's run a
test for the mic
he goes he goes i don't even know what
to say he said the mic on those
is better than the mics that i'm telling
people to get for the podcast
so anyway my wife got him for me for
christmas so
good wife well played wife yes she
played very well
and they are they're remarkable yeah
i've got so i've got the pros i'm a
airport evangelist and i went the day
that the airport pros came out i was in
the apple store the day that
the airport pro max's came out i had a
pre-order through a buddy
and um i have to say out of the pros and
the pro maxes i get a lot more use out
of the pros
reason being that those are they're a
heavy beast to
throw around but you are right that is a
one unit
podcast studio that and a laptop with
full charge
and you can do a podcast from anywhere
on the planet which is pretty incredible
yeah i i well you know maybe we'll talk
about it but
i think we're right in the middle of
what i call the great reshuffle
and i think we're moving from uh being
used to and having skill sets
designed for the physical world and we
are moving
into the digital world and you need
very different skill sets um but
as you've just mentioned time space and
geography are collapsing
and you know you're in newcastle and i
don't need any coal
so i don't need to go dude i spent this
sunday
i got invited for a coffee from a friend
podcaster who's also newcastle
and he's a local lad working class local
lad
and i was making jokes about the fact oh
what are we gonna go and do we're gonna
go and shovel coal
he took me to us the oldest railway line
in the world is in just outside of
newcastle
and it's still got a functioning steam
train and the shovel i [ __ ] you not the
shoveling coal
into it it pulls up outside of the
station the guy's got a flat cap on
he's got like black lung him and his
father his father's lost a couple of
vertebrae it was so realistic
but dude so i've heard you talk about
what you've just mentioned there
this changing of the dynamic which is
offering up opportunities to people with
what would have been previously useless
but now very useful
characteristics that they have so
someone i saw this meme
a while ago this is so you i saw a meme
a little while ago
and it was a guy a really sort of big
buff guy in a smart shirt
at the front of a bed bath and beyond
store
and it just had it just had this thought
bubble coming out the side of its head
and he said 500 years ago i would have
been a proud warrior
yes
this is the other the i call it the
great on shuffling but the other one
that i also use for shorthand is revenge
of the nerds
basically what's happening is and and
that's
that mean so we could spend the rest of
the podcast talking about why memes
have the effect they do on people it's
something i've studied a lot of and
and we'll get into why but
anyway that meme nails it and that's why
it's so
funny it's funny because it's true
and and the whole idea
in in in if you looked at the forbes of
uh
500 the first one they ever did you know
that's the rich person list
they did the first one they did in i
think 1982
if you looked at that what you would
find is
the majority of people on the list
inherited their money
okay the rest of the people on the list
made it through physical things real
estate
oil steel etc
obviously uh we we're not burying the
lead because everyone knows who's on
that list today
and they are all symbol manipulators
and so i've been using that term for a
long time
because it's what i am right i i don't
make anything with my hands i mean
uh it's all thought right
and bill gates doesn't make anything he
figured out a way to turn his thoughts
into billions and billions of dollars
because once the thought is on the
software
whatever make one ship a million ship 10
million ship 100 million doesn't matter
the unit cost of all the other ones is
zero
so as we shift it into this digital
world and and i kind of mark
maybe 2014 thereabouts i started to
really notice it and
then so i started talking about it then
but not a lot because
a lot of people look at me like are you
barking mad mate i mean what's going on
with you
covet happened and and trends
that might have taken maybe as long as a
decade
got collapsed into a year so
um skype you know
no no disrespect to skype but
zoom comes in and eats
skype's lunch and i found out why that
was by the way
they did it because skype isn't meant
for multiple
uh participants uh it's great for what
we're doing
fantastic i use skype all the time to
talk to friends all over the world
zoom is designed to have multiple
participants
and the whole experience was designed
keeping in mind that people are that
this is not a phone call
right so mindset meant a lot but
but the point is um ideas about
geography like so i just hired a new
colleague
and he's in bangalore india and
and so he he's actually outside of
bangalore but
but so let me tell you how he is a
fantastic example of the trend
to digital and what that means so number
one
his opportunity set over the last year
exploded open he was no longer
having to look for jobs in his geography
he could look for jobs anywhere in the
world
the prejudice against letting people do
that evaporated
right because of kovid and so all of a
sudden
time space geography collapsed
number two i didn't look at his cv
his cv was twitter and i watched him
for nine months so you go
from an accreditation an imperator
from some very high and mighty
institution
but all that piece of paper a diploma
all that says
is uh jim this suggests
that jim might be good at this
really uh because you know i
my kids went to really great schools my
daughter went to yale my other two went
to notre dame
i mean these are really great degrees in
the u.s and they're all very talented
luckily but
you know we were talking about it and
you know they were talking about great
inflation especially at places like the
ivys everyone gets
a's well okay that means
no one gets a's but so it's just the
what peop the game people started
playing was i just got to get in
i got to get that stamp that from the
ivy
and i'm gold in the old days that was
true
nowadays your
resume or your cv is
you show it every day um on social media
in blogs and podcasts and everything
and it grows and so the way i look at it
if you were a bitcoin
uh aficionado you'd say proof of work
well that's actually what's happening
now so vatsil who i hired
he had a long history of proof of work
that he was clever that he was able
in with technology all of those things i
got to see
before even getting on the first zoom
with him
the third thing is
the the way you think
a linear thought process was rewarded
in the physical world a non-linear
thought process
is going to be rewarded in the digital
world
and we can talk a little bit more about
what that means if you want
and then finally the idea
that you that the
leverage the digital world gives you
i mean archimedes would be like what
i mean because i i have a lot of friends
who are
single shops and the leverage that they
can
gain through multiple distribution
platforms through
you know selling a writing course
selling a speaking course selling a blah
blah
i just was on with another brit and uh
it was a very fine guy and and
he he makes all of his money on youtube
and
so the thing that i found as kind of the
that flipped the switch so to speak
so max planck the physicist said
famously that
uh progress happens one funeral at a
time
meaning that the old guard has their
points of view
not very few of them retain beginner's
mind
and they ossify and frankly they're
wrong
but they're they're the ones in the
dean's chairs
they're the ones who are determining who
gets to go to oxbridge
you know so they die off and then the
new ideas
replace them and then repeat rinse and
repeat
that's gone it's gone because
kobit forced the world this was a world
reset and so it wasn't like it was just
the united states that had a lockdown
the uk had a lockdown
brazil had a lockdown bangalore had a
lockdown
and so we were all in the same digital
boat together and so
it out of necessity erased those prior
prejudices that would have kicked in
absent covet so i mean
and the other things that it it has
affected are
really profound but it has kicked us
into
the digital age i think maybe five to
ten years before we would have fully
been there
kovid was the best thing to happen to
talented people in the developing world
and the worst thing to happen to
talentless people
in the developed world absolutely true
um i also learned about conceptual
inertia
from uh intellectual ideas historian
a guy called thomas moynihan who's just
written a history of existential risk
so the book is the history of x-risk uh
humanity and how it discovered its own
capacity for extinction
and um what he talks about there is that
i can't remember who it says history
doesn't crawl it leaps but you do very
much
get um somebody proposes a new model
heliocentric uh universe to
geocentric universe change um then
people resist the model then
the model actually becomes proven or
more people get on board with it
and it actually becomes widely accepted
intellectually or even rationally but
the substrate
the source code upon which society is
built lags behind
so so so slowly the
big organizations the bureaucracies they
take ages to catch up
the litigation that takes ages to catch
up and then the culture comes along
really slow just lumbering behind and
what you get with that is this
conceptual inertia
and um yeah there's a lot of that term
conceptual inertia it's awesome i use it
all the time now
uh you get the forcing function if you
have this forcing function it
it doesn't permit anyone anymore it's
tightened the bottleneck
so much for all of this stuff the
extraneous [ __ ] had to go
it's like if you don't if you don't
understand how to do remote working
properly
how to use monday.com or notion
or asana or whatever teamflow
program it is that you're using if you
can't do video conferencing rory
sutherland
already had zoom fridays
in his company
four plus years ago zoom friday
surprised me
so rory is a great guy i'm interviewing
him for infinite loops on friday
your last one with him your last one
with him i listened to while i was in
dubai is preparation for my one with him
dude the guy is a the man is a force of
nature
he truly is he truly is i mean
oh my god he there he he frames things
so well that
i've always believed that if you can
frame things you can get people to
understand things they can't understand
with the wrong frame rory
is maybe one of the best
and most skilled reframers of
anyone i've ever talked to he is
brilliant he is brilliant and in
addition
such a lovely man and what a great sense
of humor he says
i love talking to him i on on this point
it's sort of interesting so um
uh for example nick bostrom uh
existential risk
i'm sure you're familiar with nick he's
not adopted yeah
you're right so but but he's
he's you should read him but who i even
recommend you read more
is a book i reread called the beginning
of infinity
by david deutsch who is a quantum
physicist at oxford
and he does such an incredible
job of building the intellectual
scaffolding
for why when the enlightenment happened
all of a sudden we figured a ton of [ __ ]
out
because the he says basically man
humans we are universal connectors and
explainers and
what he means by that is
pre the enlightenment the gods were in
control
why did this happen the gods did it okay
and then the church which was
representing the gods
they said no no no we know because we we
have a line directly to
that it was a god um anyway
the enlightenment came along and they're
like no
dare to know you know and and
ironically they used as uh isaac newton
used um
uh as the the or the saying for the
society
um uh the uh take no one's word for it
um you know that you know that sir isaac
newton when he discovered his theory of
gravity do you know what was happening
then i do the plague yes yeah
well so i'm a huge fan of isaac newton
for a variety of reasons because he was
weird as hell is that why yes he's one
of the weirdest humans in history is
that why
absolutely barking mad totally crazy and
and totally crazy if you go through his
his other books right all the other
stuff it's all on alchemy
yeah you know and he was insane
the other thing that i liked about him
was he was a spiteful bugger
he used to like go to public hangings
and stuff didn't he
he loved it and so at the same time
there was a fellow in germany named
leibniz
who was a dwarf okay but
leibniz was also a genius and he came up
with basically with calculus one could
argue a little ahead of
newton newton was a master of public
relations and he's like no no no no
do you know one of his most famous lines
which is if i have seen further than
others it was
because i was able to stand on the
shoulders of giants yeah
that was a dig it leibnitz he was
no one knows this but it's kind of like
andrew marbell to his coin mistress
and your quaint honor turned to dustin
into ashes all my lust
the graves are fine in private place but
none i think due to their embrace
you know what quaint was elizabethan
slang for
the woman's genitals
[Laughter]
so was a low-key dig
but perfect because it it met its target
it was not a weapon of mass destruction
it was a smart bomb
and it the only one who got it
was the man that was aimed at right wow
he's saying that because i'm a dwarf
[Laughter]
that's so pretty so so newton is just
such a fascinating character i mean
because
the other the other great use of newton
is he lost a fortune in the south sea
trading skin
yes and and and it caused him to lament
that he could measure the motion of
heavenly bodies but not the madness of
men
and i i used to have a graph i don't use
powerpoint very much anymore because i
i find that when you don't use any
visuals people actually pay much greater
attention to you um
but if i if i do use them i only use a
few
uh and one of the great ones that we
used to use uh
for a long time was a chart of the south
sea bubble
and then a chart of the nasdaq during
the dot-com era
and obviously of course
well actually correlations don't
aren't causation no but it's a great
example
you got to give me that and and so
newton
was just he's another great example
because one of the most brilliant men to
live
right i will concede and stipulate that
barking mad
most people don't know that about him
but still
don't don't confuse the message
physics with the messenger
right because that's what peop again
human operating system
we we bollocks that up all the time so
well
let's let's just dig into that so
separating the art from the artist
or the message from the messenger is
something that previously we were able
to do
because we the eye of sauron and the
sword of damocles wasn't hanging over
everyone in the same way that it is now
i wonder whether we're actually starting
to optimize
for people who are slightly less extreme
than that
isaac newton wouldn't make it through
university and being published
now let's say that there is a degree
of insanity that needs to tinge the top
geniuses
genie i let's say that there's a an
amount of
insanity or craziness or no [ __ ] given
that has to be
it layers that right but now
that's an existential threat to the
thing that you are supposed to be
bringing to the market
wow that is a really interesting
observation
um so we're optimizing for uh
more normal yeah the palatable version
of that
i i have to think about that i love that
i don't think about
i don't either because
so i'm thinking of a couple of so i'm a
big philosophy and
an enlightenment type reader i love it
and i hate the way people use
enlightenment because it's all you know
peace and love and you know we're gonna
just
everybody's going to be happy no that
isn't what enlightenment is
enlightenment is truth realization i am
not enlightened
let me hasten to say that but i've read
a lot
of the writers on the topic and the one
who i
uh connect with the most is a guy by the
name of jed mckenna but what i got to
tell you
about jed mckenna speaks to your point
jed mckenna is not his real name or
their
real name jed mckenna is a completely
fictional character
that this author devised to tell
us that we're all fictional characters i
love that very meta
but why do i know that he's the real
deal
precisely because he's nowhere
he doesn't have a twitter account he
doesn't have facebook
he doesn't have instagram this guy could
be monetizing his reputation
to the tune of i would i would
conservatively say
5 million u.s a year if he wanted to
because i've run into like his hardcore
supporters and
a they don't know who he is which i
think is cool
but b so he solved for that that way
um another example is so
like a guy i've had on the podcast brian
romelli
so so brian
he's got a big twitter presence um
he's got some really interesting ideas
that have proven over time because he's
he's written about them for
20 years and if you go back like i do
and
read his original stuff he's pretty bang
on
but he he he leans into it
he basically in his bio he says i'm a
charlatan
i'm i'm uh i'm i'm a i'm a thinker of
uh of uh prohibited thoughts
um and and so of course
what he does with that is he draws
people who who like those misfit toys
to him so you know he's got a he's got
110 000 followers on twitter
and he's got a very active uh sub stack
i don't know what it's on but
so here's another guy who solved for it
right
i think your question or observation
that i need to think about is does
this affect a large enough cohort
so that it retards
innovation i don't on the face of it
just
given the speed of everything that of
innovation
i gotta say probably not but you know i
was
again just having a conversation with my
wife who you know never wants to talk to
me about anything because she's like
no no you i don't i'm not going down a
rabbit hole with you for three hours
but this was a conversation she was
actually interested in which was
like was why is tim cook highly thought
of at apple i mean
and i said well you know she was like
he's no steve jobs
and i'm like well no of course he's no
steve jobs
they needed a steve jobs to get to where
they are right now
but now tim you're looking at some of
the cool stuff that's coming out from
apple
and on top of it he's a much more normal
guy and but so what did he do
he decided i'm going to create such a
fortress
that no matter what i'm going to be able
to
fend off the attacks now that happens
it's like
hemingway's line how did you go bankrupt
gradually and then suddenly
right so am am i open-minded to the idea
that some nutcase in a
garage somewhere um probably in austin
now or maybe miami
um is going to come up with a thing
that obsoletes the ipad
i think it will happen i mean i think
what you'll see
is you'll see clear transparent
things that can fold like a newspaper
but when you open them up
you can have whatever you want on it you
could have a sports you could have a
rugby match going on up here
you could have the the times of london
to read over here you could have twitter
open down here
and it will all be seamless so
i fully expect to see that in the next
10 years where do people start with jed
mckenna what's the first thing they read
so so he's got a three-part um
uh uh a trilogy uh called uh spiritual
enlightened
enlightenment the damnedest thing
that'll do
but but just let me put a warning label
on here okay
so i will
i will put up again and i'll tag you on
twitter
i will put up two essays that i suggest
people read by my friend
dan jeffries before they go into jed
because jed
is hardcore it's not all
puppies and and wonderful things with
him
uh but but
he's very worthwhile with that that'll
be that'll be linked in the show notes
below
so going back to what you were saying
there um about
hard to fake signals of authenticity
that's what i think you were talking
about and i saw this with sam harris
last year towards the start of this year
and last year
what i came to believe was that
sam had a non-typical perspective
which made him unpopular with both sides
of the aisle
the way that you can guarantee
disagreement in 2021 is to be in the
middle because when you're out on the
extremes you guarantee
agreement from at least one side when
you're in the middle you guarantee
disagreement from both
so what that made me think was i can
have
greater faith that sam believes what
sam's saying
because he has to pay such a high cost
to hold the particular positions that he
does
that again that is a wonderful um
uh heuristic to use uh because
you're right um and this is another part
of this great reshuffling that i've
talked about
so what's happening there is that
uh traditional media has gone all pravda
so but for both sides right so so if
you're
uh uh uh to the left you're gonna watch
msnbc in the us
you're gonna watch msnbc and cnn and if
you're to the right you're going to
watch fox
what people don't understand is it's all
propaganda
all of it and it is so
shocking to me i stopped watching tv
news
10 years ago because i was noticing it
starting down that path
trump only accelerated it listen man the
greatest thing that ever happened to the
new york times was donald trump getting
elected president
because they were going broke and then
all of a sudden
donald trump got elected president they
decided you know what we're going to
chuck
this gray lady [ __ ] and we are going
to go full pravda
and we don't give a [ __ ] if it's right
or not it's going to be anti-donald
trump
and then you had like fox doing the
well if donald trump says it's right
that it's right god damn it
and so you had these two contenders
right
both of which are spewing [ __ ]
and these poor people and
again this is a a generational thing
mostly the people i'm trying to convince
to stop watching tv news are people
older than 70 right it that the habit
for them of watching tv news back when
it was walter
cronkite they just can't they can't stop
doing it
and and and younger people are getting
it much faster
but so so what happened to traditional
media
back to sam harris was and
matt i always mispronounced his name
matt tobi tibby
uh he's a great writer very much to the
left
i used to follow him um when he was the
lead writer for the rolling stone
because i think one should so my own
version is i don't have a party
uh i'm the only thing that defines me is
i'm fiercely anti-authoritarian
of either the left or the right i
i just it always leads to bad things in
my opinion if you study history
so but my i mean like if i went through
my political opinions
some people depending on the order in
which i listed them
some people would say you're a left
winger
um other people would say what that's a
right-wing
thought and and so
i'll just give you a couple of for
instances so i think all drugs should be
legal
um because the war on drugs is a sham
and it has corrupted so many different
levels of our societies
that i mean portugal is a great example
they basically decriminalized they
didn't make them legal
but uh guess what happened you know like
all of the bad crime all that just
went plunging i think that all
uh non-violent drug uh
offenders in prison should be released i
mean that was
like they were saying to me when trump
lost and they were saying what would be
his big [ __ ] you to everybody and i said
if i was his advisor and believe me no
fan of donald trump so i
if if he asked me to be his advisor i'd
say [ __ ] off
but but if i was if i was going to be
able to
be a whisper something in his ear it
would have been
pardon every non-violent
person in prison on a drug charge can
you imagine we would have put such a
stone in the shoe of everyone right
because they would have thought hang on
this is so disjointed from what we
we thought that he would have done yeah
man i mean
dude when you're talking about that this
sort of nuance of opinions this is
jordan petersonism from years ago
he said it in the interview with the gq
lady i can't remember her name they sent
kathy newman away put her on a short
course of steroids and training
and she came she came back having read a
little bit more uh sort of enlightenment
philosophy
and that you know the one that i mean
well they didn't they didn't turn his
microphone on and all that sort of stuff
and he said in that and it's the first
time that i heard it and i've never got
rid of it
he said if i know one of your
perspectives and from it
i can accurately predict everything else
that you believe then you're not a
serious thinker it's
very unlikely there is no reason in hell
that your view on abortion should be
impacted
by your view on immigration or your view
on
the level of corporate tax or your view
on gun rights
but because we've lumped these things
together you end up
with an increasingly partisan level of
politics that then gets fueled by a
media that needs to drive clicks
clicks are driven by an algorithm which
is enforced by things that you either
really hate or really agree with
and it's when people say like i often
get asked
one of the shows why why are we becoming
increasingly polarized i'm like
how can we not be right how it would be
so unbelievable if we weren't up against
all of this
so so we know a lot about algorithms
that's what we do
uh the algorithms for traditional media
are
are optimized for fear uncertainty and
doubt
and it's much easier to to outrage
people
so they're they're maxed out on outrage
items on both sides
right um and and they keep people
i i've i've likened it to an emotional
plague
and because what's happened is we
haven't given up on religion we just
changed the pews
right so the new religion is politics
and total compliance
with the belief talking points if you
will
is the price you must pay to be thought
of as a good
person oh you're right i'm like i'm a
heritage
i i proudly call myself a heretic i'm an
apostate
come at me do whatever you want but this
also happens
because i don't give a [ __ ] what people
think about me
i i don't i don't want to offend people
and by that i mean
look i've been so lucky and so blessed
in life and like one of the things that
i enjoy doing is working with people
uh younger people especially not just in
my field but in a bunch
of fields i like this idea teach you
know
tren griffith who i just did a podcast
with yesterday and he flipped it on me
and he started interviewing me but he's
got this great idea which is fits in
with karma
but he calls it give to get
and what he means is if he can only
teach
one lesson to a younger person it's
give and don't expect or hope for
getting
from lo so let's say i give to you chris
and the wrong way to think about it is
now god damn it chris owes me
something that's reciprocity right and
uh
it's in the book influence and everybody
knows about it trends
take on this and rory i'm going to ask
him about it on friday because i can i
already know he's going to say but uh
trends take is no no no karma
you put it out and it you know what it
might
not come back from chris in fact chris
might
do something really dastardly to you it
comes
back though the wheel of karma just
keeps going round
and round and round and you build good
karma or bad karma
and it comes back and now if you want to
make that much less mystic you're
programming your brain and you don't
even know it
right so we're all meta programmers of
our own brain and we program our brains
with the stories we tell ourselves
about ourselves and so if you're putting
a lot of bad karma out there
what your brain is doing is it's going
oh
okay he likes bad algorithms the
algorithms being reinforced
yes i will oblige him he thinks the
world is an
ugly uh place full of trouble and strife
that's what i'm gonna serve up for him
because my recticular activating system
you know if i was talking to a
neurobiologist that's what he'd talk
about or she'd talk about
if i'm talking to one of these
enlightenment people they would say
karma
but it's it's not this mystic thing
it's it's programming and you're
self-programming yourself
every day and that's how that all comes
about
it's like i have like four questions i
wrote a piece called
a long thread actually a series of
threads called the thinker and the
prover
and it's on an old model uh by a guy by
the name of
leonard orr um and he and he separates
the brain
into the thinker and the prover and the
thinker can think anything at once
it can think three impossible things
before breakfast as the queen said to
alice in the wonderland series
but once the thinker has thought it out
and latched on i believe this
that's another reason why i present all
of my ideas as hypotheses or thesis
because the minute you say i believe
what your brain hears is
this is true and not only is this is
true
but this defines you as a human being
and that story starts revving up but
so what happens is back to politics
right
so let's say well take me
as an example i am in favor of a woman's
right to have an abortion
uh i am opposed to capital punishment
because i don't think the state should
be able to have
the right to take a human being's life
uh but i also think
that um the taxes done wrongly will
actually
get less revenue for the government than
more
that's that's kind of a classic
right-wing point of view
the others are kind of classic
left-wing's point of view
immigration i think and i man do i stir
the hornet's nest when i put this up on
twitter or say it in a podcast
i think that the united states right now
still
still after everything has
a huge advantage that other countries
don't have and that is
the smartest people in the world want to
live and work here
and my idea is we should
let them and that means if they come
here to go to university
and you know so i do it i stage it and
first i say stem degrees right
science technology et cetera we should
staple a green card to it
and say welcome to america go create
and and yet because of this this whole
orthodoxy
the the and and label thinking that's
the other thing that drives me
mad people are we're word thinkers and
labels negate us and and and so the
minute you
label something you know rules for
radicals that's what he says
label personalize it stalin knew this
stalin was one death is a tragedy
a million is a statistic you
people are simply not going to get
worked up over a million deaths but when
it's ivan
who you know and you know his daughter
and his wife
that's going to really rev you up so the
point being though
that traditional media
knows what's happening and all of their
best people
sam harris uh matthew
uh a ton of like first-rate writers but
dude
look at sub stack at the moment matthew
iglesias has just left
vice which was already a splinter off
from the legacy media world that just
started to come alongside but they never
kind of really were and they got a tv
show and it's still
but they were already a heterodox
organization
and he said no this is this is still too
bureaucratic for me
i'ma go i'm gonna go do a sub stack yep
and that is what's gonna happen writ
large and it
also explains why you see this hysteria
among the traditional media because
worldwide well especially in
in america and the uk
um there was a deal and the deal was
i'm going to be a journalist i'm not
going to make gobs of money
but i'm going to have influence and i'm
going to get to know all these important
people and influence these important
people
and it was a trade you know the
hierarchy of needs
that a lot of very smart switched on
people made
going away it's going away and
so sub stack that's the future
and and you know we'll have we'll have
our own channels
right so i'm a big believer in reading
people that i know i'm going to disagree
with
just because i'm probably wrong right
that's the other thing that it drives
people crazy when i say this
but i mean empirically speaking
look at history look at what this back
to our friend isaac newton
look at what isaac newton believed and
with
the exception of that gem about uh
physics and calculus
every one of his beliefs were wrong they
were wrong
and he was the smartest guy on the
planet leibniz not withstanding
uh but the point is when you have
context
right it's like people getting all
worked up about in this country thomas
jefferson thomas jefferson owns slaves
tear down all his statues you know
boo this man okay
let's put some context in let's
understand
that as horrible as slavery was
and is an abomination
and something that all throughout human
history was practiced
widely um go all the way back to
the the helots in sparta and the slaves
in greece
they actually had a more enlightened
attitude about it than we then
we in the west did because they you
could make them free
and you know some of the greatest stoics
were started life as slaves
and so as the world
progressed and we became more
sensible in my opinion right slavery
that's an abomination
we six hundred thousand americans died
over it
um the the most uh uh
the highest death count of any american
war any war we've ever engaged in
including our little spat with our
friends from the one against
themselves was the one against ourselves
it was brother against brother
and six hundred 000 americans died
for an idea and that idea was
slavery is an abomination it
has to be it must be abolished
and and then what happened well as you
said earlier in our in our conversation
the cultural belief that that layer
for a lot of people even enlighten
people and this is what i want to
emphasize here even for the most
enlightened people
they still had these awful beliefs in
their head
right because they had grown up in in a
world that was described have you read
cloud atlas
by um i know i'm blanking on his name
but
anyway so
the book is so much better i enjoyed the
movie for just for fun
but but the book is like his
magnum opus and and it's brilliant on so
many different levels but
one of them is that you know it's kind
of a zen like we're cr we're all
we're all connected through time and and
but one of them one of the stories as
you'll remember from the movie was
the the awakening if you will
of the lawyer about the evils of slavery
and and he went from you know being the
agent of his
wicked father-in-law who had very
neanderthal views about the world to
being quite awake and
his best friend being an escaped slave
who saved his life
and and so the the the point
the the larger point i think is people
fall
into this without knowing they're
falling into it
and suddenly so i i equate dogma
with death with brain death if if you at
your point about um
yeah if you i'm
i'm really not interested in talking to
you because i i don't think i can change
your mind
that's another one of my beliefs i can't
change you chris
only you can change you i can help you
if you're looking for that kind of help
but if you're not i'm not going to help
at all
maybe someone else will but
that has to come from within and and
once i really realized that it
you know i'm not so smart it took me a
while to get all this stuff
but i was working with an employee and
i'm kind of like
you know he just kept making the same
mistake same mistake same mistake
and i got really frustrated until i
finally figured out
i can't change him until he wants to
change this
nothing will change and in fact he will
dig in
he will dig in on the thing i'm trying
to change
so i was doing him a disservice
trying to get him to see the light
when you are when you are mired in a
belief system that you
tie to yourself you literally can't see
the light
because your brain these wonderful
quantum computers that we carry around
with us
have amazing abilities to say
nope nope nope
and if do i agree with it yep
yep yep and so people are honestly
surprised when something that they
deeply believe
is proved fundamentally wrong and they
will go to massive lengths to deny it
flat earth society my friend tim irvin
who has wait but why
he has a great story about this so
there's a movie about the flat earth
society right so
today in 2021 with
all of the photographs that we have from
space and from the moon
and from all of our satellites showing
the sort of round not really round but
sort of round
world on which we make our lives a
interesting thing and and and they will
basically invent anything to tell you
you're wrong no
you were hypnotized by aliens this is
all fake
and what's interesting is when you're
trying to convince people of deeply
wrong
beliefs the best place to go and study
is cults
because cults have this
down to a science
and and here's the other thing that i
often say and people don't believe me
you want to know who the easiest people
to fool are
the smartest people why
are the smartest people the easiest to
fool because they're smart
because they understand they know like
people
always say well i'm not smart they know
they're smart come on
you know and so their brain is like
i am smart i will automatically see all
of the [ __ ] that they're trying to
sling at me
no you won't no you won't that's the way
that they get their hooks in
it's like one of the best stories is one
of the
biggest not biggest but one of the most
interesting victims of the bernie madoff
scam was a guy who published a book
about
how cons work and how to avoid them
it's just like perfect you can't make
this [ __ ] up
and so the other thing that's
interesting about smart people
what else are smart people good at smart
people are
really good at building bulletproof
narratives
that they first convince themselves of
i think you know and whatever and and
and then
so they they keep iterating on that
narrative until it's like
pretty bulletproof and then they go and
convince a bunch of other people
because they're smart and so one of my
heroes
uh richard feynman the physicist like
the quote i use all the time is the
first rule is you must not fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
it's like this whole behavioral finance
thing i know that i would fall for
every single one of those biases i know
i would
i know myself well enough so i yeah oh
yeah
so what did i do it's like a friend did
this survey
about behavioral biases and he talked to
a bunch of
investors or advisors et cetera and the
question was
what is your biggest behavioral bias and
how do you deal with it
and a lot of my friends you know they
said uh you know
uh confirmation bias uh survivorship
bias et cetera and they went into these
long
and this is what i do to deal with it
and and my answer was simple
what is your biggest behavioral bias
and i said being a human being and it
said
how do you solve for it i'm a quant
so does that leave out a lot am i
leaving
knowledge potentially that is not
available to me as a quant
you bet i am you bet i am but the
idea is the trade-off the base rate
if you will directionally is good
because virtually all of the greatest
meltdowns ever and
boy i've been around for a lot of them
take super super smart people give them
leverage
basically unlimited leverage and
well one of the one of my favorite
mental models or biases is to
never multiply by zero and god i try and
tell the boys this all the time i have
about 500 guys and girls that work for
me for my events company between the age
of 18 and 22
and there are essentially an unlimited
number of
zeros to multiply by when you're that
age and um
just trying to highlight a couple of
those texting while you drive
but tell me tell me what you're gaining
what is the play stupid games win stupid
prizes like right like what's the prize
that you're getting for texting while
you drive
unprotected sex on a one night stand but
tell me tell me that's that is a big
fat zero that you're going to multiply
there my friend you can have spent
the last four years of your life saving
up your money you've got your mortgage
deposit ready for the house you're going
to buy a house quicker than anybody else
that you know you're ready to move away
you've got
the visas even sorted you've got this
perfect graduate job out in america
that's a hundred times 150 times 2 000
times
i just got someone pregnant and i'm 22
years old that's an 18 year that's an 18
year quarter of a million pound
liability that you've just created there
zero
you can spend all the time that you want
in the gym working on my body i'm doing
my nutrition i'm sleeping right i'm
eating right i'm
drinking i'm watching i'm working hard
on my form i'm doing my prehab and my
rehab i'm rolling my body out
i decide to ride a bicycle without a
helmet or i decide to
text while i drive if if you're very
dead
it doesn't matter how fit you are that's
a big fat zero
and um yeah this is one of the the
unknown catastrophes that we can
encounter
are inherently catastrophic and
it's you don't see it until it happens
and it's only with the benefit of
hindsight
a good example of this i've ruptured my
achilles playing cricket last year
it was the first time that i'd played
cricket in 10 years since i'd played for
i'd played for a decade took a decade
off went back first game
went into bat was in bat for 15 minutes
loving it dad was over the far side dad
was great he always used to come to the
games
ping achilles goals ended up being
not too bad of a thing actually quite an
interesting personal development
strategy
but at the time i just thought you're a
[ __ ] idiot of course this is gonna
happen
you haven't you haven't played a
plyometrically
uh demanding athletic sport
in a decade and you thought that at 32
years old you would just be able to get
back into it
and one of my friends said one of the
most common ways that he sees people get
injured
in his friend group our age group is
people that used to play a sport when
they were a kid
getting back into it about 10 years
later so this is a public service
announcement to everybody
just do do six weeks of training
condition yourself back into it do not
think that you can do the things that
you used to be able to do 10 years ago
oh man i'm going to just steal so much
stuff from you
i love to never multiply by zero that's
fantastic
um talk to me before we
finish up i've got a couple of threads
open in my mind i really want you to try
and how would you prepare for the
reshuffling
you know you have preppers out there
like the
the doomsday preppers you guys in
america love them and
they've got their bunkers underground
the reshuffling is occurring
the talents which previously served us
are no longer the ones that we can
utilize in this world that's basically
what the reshuffling is talking about
right
that what used to be a competitive
advantage no longer is
and in this new world we need to have
new modes of thinking we need to have
new skills
what would you do i take 30 years off
your life
what would you do now yeah yeah so what
i would do
is i would watch broadly
and read broadly just
like if i was going to even use a metric
to decide
what i wanted to read i would find
people that i resonated with on social
media
and i would i would take their
recommendations
and if they said hey read the beginning
of infinity by david deutsch
i would read that book and i would
i i would learn to be
endlessly curious because dorothy parker
was an american wit
uh had a wonderful uh quote which is
um curiosity is the cure for boredom
there is no cure for curiosity and
and if you can and and i find that it
becomes
almost a habit so if you
start getting curious about something
that makes you curious about other
things
and so on and so on i use the john
cleese from monty python
and so on and so on gif when i'm doing
it on twitter
but activate your mind and
this sounds like pedestrian information
but
i can't tell you how many people that
i've given this advice to and they're
like
really and i'm like yeah really
like university that wasn't your
education
that was a certification and a
socialization process
which you probably benefited from by the
way um
but now now that you've articulated now
your education begins
right and so consume as
much as you possibly can intellectually
speaking so listen to your podcast
listen to mine
listen to somebody who like listen to
sam harris
because you lit you learned by listening
to chris's podcast that sam harris is an
honest broker
because he's at risk oh that's
interesting i think i'm going to
subscribe to sam harris
and i'm going to listen i subscribe by
the way um
and and so the second thing
keep this is so hard
don't become prematurely certain
right everybody just see it immediately
like they see one thing about whatever
um one of the issues we were discussing
and and
i'm certain that this is right no you're
not
no you're not and and that
that leads to what i call deterministic
thinkers
right so we're deterministic thinkers
living in a probabilistic
world that world just got a [ __ ] ton
more probabilistic because we now it's a
universe right
and i get to i get to talk to chris and
say hey i'm looking for somebody
in the uk because i want to do this and
you've got i got right i got
just the guy for you i skype with him i
give him the job
it's done because you showed me the you
recommended him you see his record
so so the idea that that you need
or even want in a weird way
some imperator from an institution
that's going away and your imperator
is you right so
so i would do that i would really if
you took 30 years off me i would learn
how to program
because that is such an amazing skill
and elite programmers which i know a lot
about now because of what we're doing in
osam and and
friends and things man it is
it's a it's a power law it's not it's
not like an arithmetic thing
when when you are 10 times better in
programming
than this guy down here
he can't even begin you're not even
talking about the same
universe are you talking about capacity
to make money
ability to see the world happiness what
are you optimizing for here
well so what i optimize for
is knowledge because
and and by that i mean the whole
happiness thing that always has made me
shake my head because i can't figure it
out
i think that chasing happiness
as an end goal doesn't work
what makes you happy is being able in my
opinion
could be wrong but being able to do
what you want to do what animates you
when you want to do it how you want to
do it
and basically being able to do that
do you know how close do you know how
close that is to morgan housel's
description of what wealth is
so so morgan's a good friend of mine um
disclosure
um i i do know how to do what you want
when you want with who you want for as
long as you want and no one can tell you
otherwise that's his description of
wealth
bingo and he's right he's absolutely
right that's why his book i recommend
the psychology of
money fantastic book because he
understands what wealth
really is and and so many people
especially in the united states
but also the uk it's a little different
it's certainly much different in some
asian i travel a lot so i've been to
you know bhutan i've been to nepal and
i think it's great because i i think the
more you learn the better
see what am i optimizing for i'm
optimizing for learning
and and and if you optimize for that
the rest kind of takes care of itself
and by that i mean
so i'm an asset manager i've been an
asset manager since i was 27 years old
so i've been a i've been a fiduciary all
my life all my adult life
chris i honestly can count on one hand
the number of people who i met whose
money we managed
whose goal was to make a lot of money
not even five it's actually four and i
remember each one of them
because guess what they are [ __ ]
miserable
and and they just they never have enough
and they
always want more than the next guy and
they're covetous
and they're jealous and they're envious
and those are the most destructive sins
because you can't have any fun with them
i mean at least gluttony and then you're
going to enjoy it
right so so everyone else
other than those four everyone else
became rich by doing something that
fascinated them or that they were really
good at so
you know we have some from some
professional sports people
they were just so good at it they were
optimized for it
and you know they were built for it they
lovely gene structure right but they
they
pursued it they they didn't make that
rookie mistake that you made
multiplied by zero yeah yeah they were
like oh no no no
ben injured not gonna do that so
so but every one of them and they come
from a wide variety of fields
they were obsessed almost
with something and they just wouldn't
give it they wouldn't give up
they just kept going they kept going
they kept going and guess what
as a side effect of that
they were like some of the happiest
people i've ever met in my life
it's like i'm a very cheerful person you
know
despite jed mckenna because i kind of
get to do whatever the [ __ ] i want to do
and that's wonderful here's something
for you here's something for you i want
to interject there
a lot of the time when i speak to people
um i see
a combination of a number of different
things happening survivorship bias
and and um a narrow world view from
people who
sit in a position perhaps where you are
now
where you have degrees of freedom
wealth generally lack of boss head room
above you to do the things you want etc
etc
and i often wonder about whether or not
their advice how applicable their advice
is to people who are
before them right because the person who
has the things
can talk about the model that they think
should be pursued
but hang on a second is that how you got
to where you are now is that the way
that you went through that
what are your sort of thoughts around
this is there a period is there a grind
reel that people need to go through
between sort of 20 and 40 something like
that
so again really great question i'm going
to be stealing a lot of your questions
and why when i
have people on my pleasure um so
yes there is a grind period
but to answer your question i did things
in a very unorthodox way
i started o'shaughnessy capital
management without any backers
and i believe that if i got this book
it's what works on wall street is
propping up my computer here
if i got this book published that would
make my career
so i i was i
like locked on to that how can i make
that
so um and that's a fun story and
it required a lot more than you might
think but to people looking
outside at me and
say the ages between 27 and say 45
they would have said man jim's not just
a grinder that's all he's doing
he's just grind grind grind man he's on
a plane all the time i don't want that
life
that's awful you know to me
it was like i was doing what i loved and
and so i think you need to
you need to look at what is the what is
the platform
on which we are viewing this individual
are we viewing them from the outside do
we understand
that what looks like a super bad grind
to us
is actually like sparking joy in them
dude
let me tell you you brought tim cook up
earlier on i was sat down with one of
the head
branding guys for apple in the uk it's
the first
we've been shut down for ages it was the
first lunch that i had in like six
months that wasn't made by me
um and we sat down news tell me this
story about
about tim and uh he was at this private
super aaa level and above employee
seminar thing out in america and tim's
giving this
tim's giving this talk and um someone
asked a question
to do with the passion
should i follow what i really love
should i do what feels
fun to me um i'm trying to do that
but the work the work is hard i
i thought that following your passion
was supposed to be easy
and tim said no no no following your
passion
will be the hardest thing that you will
do in your life
he said you will have to lift the
heaviest weight
that you have ever lifted but the tools
will feel light
wonderful wonderful
tim is absolutely right it's so funny
you know
i'm feeling young union synchronicities
here because we were having this
conversation last night about
with my wife about you know why apple
why why
do i still think apple's great and i
said because it's a whole different
deal tim cook's
tools uh have to be by necessity they're
different than steve jobs
tools and i so
vibe with that statement because
it's true i mean listen chris
i worked crazy hours here's another one
that i often say and i can tell by just
looking at the person i know you'll get
it because you
this is the kind of guy you are but
think like an owner
if you can think like an owner as
opposed to an employee
you retain you just naturally retain
much more agency within yourself
you retain much more responsibility
within yourself
you don't blame other people's when you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
and that's the other thing that i tell
people who
are kind of afraid to fail
i do not know including these four
miserable [ __ ] who only want it to be
rich
i do not know a single person
who is rich who didn't fail
sometimes spectacularly and it was all
in how
they reacted to that so i
i mean i have a whole list right i i i
put it up sometimes
mistakes were made and yes by me
[Laughter]
and the way i look at it is i learned
so much from those failures
that i couldn't have gone to the next
level of where i went
in my career without learning that right
so think like an owner it's hard for
people to think that way
because it just is but
the the the quote from tim cook is
absolutely right
what looks and feels at the time like
oh you know sometimes we're all human
beings right sometimes when you're
sitting in a hotel
i remember i had to do an actual book
tour for my third book how to retire
rich which
by the way was the only book that i
wrote for a general audience
and i was on oprah winfrey for it and
that was a trip
and uh anyway but this the grind was
like
deadly it was like morning you gave a
talk and at breakfast and then you did a
talk at a lunch and then you
did tv and then you got on a plane and
went to the next market
insane like that mentality that was 1997
my miracle year is tren griffith would
say
and and so at the end i'm like
okay i just i
i don't think i can eat another powdered
egg i you know i i just i just can't
but then i would just like rub myself up
because i'm like i would
just remind myself dude you just saw
oprah winfrey man
you have women coming up to you in
airports going are you jim o'shaughnessy
and that's cool that's cool
and so looking from without there was a
lot of woe is me oh i'm not home and
you know i came home every weekend
because my kids were young and i wanted
to see my kids and that was a deal
breaker for me
and so other people would say well but
that just added to it
no get when you are
doing that grind when you are lifting
that heavy weight
and the tools are light one of the
things you got to think about too
is you can put provisos
and heretofores if we're going to get
legalistic in here
into your own game plan one of my
provisos was
i don't care where i am on this
three-week
national tour and canada i am going to
be home
friday afternoon get my kids at school
spend the weekend with them
fly out sunday night and it was that
hard on me
sure maybe i was probably in a beautiful
place like whistler
in canada and maybe i just wanted to
hang but it was more important that i
had that built in
to the deal because that was more
important to me
and and so i can hear somebody right now
listening and saying well
[ __ ] you know i work for whatever
lloyd's or
and you know they uh they have this
social media they
i have to be anonymous and okay be
anonymous
doesn't matter uh jesse livermore one of
the most brilliant guys in markets that
i have never
met he's an osam partner uses our data
and writes these incredible pieces
i had a guy call me from um one of the
most prestigious universities in the
united states and he was like
dude will you tell that guy that if he's
going to do that again
to submit an application for a phd in
finance and he'll get it
with that was that would be his thesis
he's anonymous
nobody knows who he is and now we're
coming full circle back to this new age
right the quality of jesse's work
is everything you can and the other
thing that's interesting about
being anonymous is remember that
messenger message
uh hating the messenger and and so
therefore hitting the message
if you hate him you don't hate him
because you don't have any idea who the
hell he is
but you hate his message okay that's
fine that's fair game
but so
the last thing i would say is
don't spend if i'm a huge
fan of writing with your hand
there's there's reasons for why this
works and you're a lefty too
i am yes and
so if you want to know the fastest way
to know whether you know something or
not
try to write it out because
if you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about it will show up on the
page
and you'll be like oh i thought i knew
this
no you didn't know it and so like
another thing that i do
is i i reckon i i recommend that like
people come to me and they're like how
do i do this like i have all of these
liabilities
or these perceptions of a ceiling
and i'm like perception is reality man
if if you believe and i cannot tell you
the number of people that i've worked
with on this and and the ones that got
it
soared right they
put themselves in their own prison of
their beliefs
right and it's hard to come up with an
escape plan if you don't know you're in
jail
and and so when you work with them
and you have them write things out
they're like
i can't believe i just wrote this down
that i believed this
this is like [ __ ] why would i ever
believe this
so so write write about what you want to
be write about how you get there
are is everyone going to make it no i
mean
that's the way the world works and and
you know the other thing finally
retain your agency
uh timothy leary who was vilified in
this country
the perfect scapegoat uh he
actually was a very brutal professor at
harvard but he also
kind of like isaac newton liked the
limelight
he liked the people talking about him
and so nixon was like
oh i'm gonna make all of those
non-addictive drugs
class one and you're gonna go to fed max
for using them
and finally that bit of ridiculousness
is going away and
they're finding miraculous recoveries
from like ptsd and everything else
anyway larry was a psychologist who was
actually pretty
gifted and and so he said we get
imprinted
at a certain age and it's very difficult
to undo that in print
later on as you might guess
larry suggested that lsd might be a very
good agent to help you on
print and actually they're finding that
in the research they're doing
particularly with veterans with ptsd
miraculous recoveries and how any sane
individual could be against this i just
don't know these people
like literally tried to kill themselves
but but so what he said was you get
imprinted with a loser script
or a winner script the loser script
what do they do chris
it's your fault it's let's let's say i
suck at this
podcast and and people are laughing and
jim had an off day you know he was
pretty stupid
the loser script is that was chris's
fault
and i i was because of skype
i didn't like skype i like zoom and and
i was hungry
just you're just gonna see this laundry
list everything but
me that's a loser script
and if you can figure that out and there
are ways by the way to reverse that
and and if you maintain your agency is
the easiest way i've found
which means you gotta own it
you can own the success but you also
gotta own the total
total snafu and
and when you do that it's uncomfortable
and it's like teddy roosevelt one of our
presidents had this great thing about
the man in the arena now we would say
the human being or
the man or the woman in the arena and
it's scary as hell
honestly i'm i just subscribed to a
friend he
finally decided he's going to write for
sub stack and charge people
and so i'm dming with him on twitter and
he's like i am
terrified that i'm going to fail and i'm
like
dude you took the first step which takes
a lot of courage
just to keep leaning into it now like
i'll
amplify you i'll say guess what i just
subscribed to
and i think you should too um
and and so i'm not i'm not
saying that this is easy
it's not i mean yeah it'd be great right
if like
what's the joke the meme about uh you
know uh
get money uh make it a zillion
bro down you know sell it that's the way
the world works
man and you know you're an entrepreneur
you know that
and and like my old joke was i would be
perfect if i didn't ever have to
employ or deal with another human being
including me by the way
man there's so much there at the very
end i'm trying to i'm trying to sort of
wrangle it all together
um we're finite creatures surrounded by
infinite complexity
so it makes sense that you're going to
be scared it makes sense that you're
going to be concerned of things because
inevitably you're in a battle against
entropy
that you can't win in the end entropy
is going to win out but my twitter bio
is correct
we locally reverse it we locally reverse
entropy
uh talking about writing the importance
of writing
forcing your thoughts into words when
you have something that's in your head
if you don't have an outlet like a
podcast or
a friend that you can have a deep
meaningful conversation with for 30
minutes
once every week which is a prescription
i give or a journal practice
morning pages or whatever it is um if
you don't have that
all of your thoughts are just notions
that these ephemeral clouds and you
can't grasp them they're not concrete
and if reading 1984 taught us anything
it's that the quality of your language
is directly proportional to the quality
of your thoughts because without the
words to describe the things you're
thinking the things you're thinking
stay inside of your own head and you
don't even understand them in terms of
concrete for yourself so that's
important as well
um talking about taking the leap and
just
sort of jumping and learning to fly on
the way down i'm someone
i haven't had a massive amount of
failures i'm um
prudent my i'm a very very sort of
prudent businessman the way that i make
my entrepreneurial decisions always errs
towards the side of caution and um
i think i have something to learn there
i'm not really too sure what it is yet i
feel like i have something
to to learn some sort of insight to
learn around
around failing or around pushing harder
failing faster i'm not really too sure
what that is yet
um but man this we could go on for
forever and ever and we will do it again
it's been
too long to get you booked in but i
won't make it this long for the next one
uh infinite loops podcast what else
should people check out podcast
uh check out osam oscars
mary.com that's where all of these
research pieces that we do have a home
uh check out um
canvas you can get to it through osam
uh we didn't even talk about that and
that's the way the world's going
uh i i we're in the fast lane of asset
management and we got a maserati
and uh it's unbelievable watching this
explosive growth it's customization
and if you've ever had a bespoke suit um
you don't want to buy one off the rack
anymore
so that's a whole different conversation
we could do an entire podcast about that
because that's what we see
coming um and
once you once you understand that you
can get
treat it like you're on savile row but
you're paying joseph a bank's prices
that's a pretty nice deal um
so check out canvas when you're there
that's interesting um and then my son
uh patrick he has like so he has an
enterprise that i have nothing to do
with
colossus it's called it's all his he
came up with it
he's killing it over there but the
reason i suggest it
is because what it's becoming
is like if you want to know about you
fill it in
you go over to colossus you type your
search term in
where there's a domain expert on it i've
come the transcript
up come com we think you should read
this
i said to him the other night at dinner
you you're chasing all the mba programs
out right
here's another digital world right
because
the leverage that is inherent in that
especially for young people
go over to colossus.com and
i'm sure you have some kind of passion
guess what
there's going to be a domain expert who
is really compelling
and what to read so check that out too
jimmy shawn see ladies and gentlemen i
will catch you next time
cheers thanks chris this was great thank
you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace